we have some breaking news that happened
about an hour ago that i want to talk
about
so uh lee zeldin
yeah he's a he's a republican rep i
believe yeah yeah and he's running he's
running in new york for the governor
someone just tried to kill him what
someone tried to stab him
and uh he's he's fine uh nobody got hurt
oh thank god he finished the speech
finish his speech you love to see it
that's pretty badass okay that way was
that a teddy roosevelt thing what was it
roosevelt
shot and
um i i'm just seeing this on twitter uh
after speaking on bail from someone just
tried stabbing new york governor
candidate lee zeldin unreal news 10 nbc
new york post i'm not sure are we seeing
more from this i i
mean there's a lot of it's going to work
let's let's can we get some is there any
more confirmation on this i want to be
very careful here i'm saying from will
chamberlain whom i trust
implicitly but i don't have further
facts it is it's so breaking it's still
only on twitter but i'm sure they'll
have news i bet post millennial has uh
it could be some random person posting
some random nonsense
you know
we're waiting for some official
confirmation
uh but i don't i don't know if i see
anything
other than some real media people just
posting a photo wow so i want to make
sure we have uh you know confirmation on
this for sure yeah
oh okay here we go looks like we've got
rochester first
uh okay there's our we got confirmation
zelda attacked at parenting campaign
stop confirmed confirmed
um let's see he was attacked at a
campaign event witness say he was giving
a speech about bail reform when a man
got on stage started yelling wrestled
with a bit and pulled out a blade
the alleged attacker was suppressed by
am vets national director joe chenelly
whoa a witness with zelda after they
texted zelda was not hurt and took the
stage again when it was over bravo good
sir
now uh scary and disgusting yes that's
terrifying
horrible unbelievable
yeah thank god he's okay absolutely and
um
and he stood stood up and gave his
speech and i man mad respect okay yes i
i got some questions marjorie okay
what is the balance right
so this conversation great we're talking
about bringing people together we see
what happens when extreme rhetoric i
mean this guy could just be not even
political he could just be mentally
unhinged we have no idea the story's
just coming in but obviously there's
toxic elements on
both sides right now on both extremes
apparently you've said some
controversial things right and we were
talking about this before
where
it it's what gets attention on issues
right
but what is that line between
like would you get as much attention
if you were like hey i'm just trying to
bring people together blah blah blah the
war is bad i agree with the left here's
i'm pro-life i agree with the right etc
or
like you were saying you know before we
went on air you were talking about
sometimes this extreme rhetoric is what
gets attention but is the extreme
rhetoric
also what leads to like bombastic is
maybe a better one bombastic yeah yeah
i'll take that i can i'm very direct
you are you don't have much of a filter
as they say well i think that if we're
going to solve problems you have to
really get down to what the what the
issue is yeah do you have an example
um yeah i don't even know if i'm allowed
to say it without getting booted off
youtube but uh uh after show nonsense
after show on saturday
sign up for the after show well j okay
so so there's an uh so here's an example
okay um i don't like nancy pelosi and
maybe this is the daily show taken out
of context so you can correct me i don't
like nancy pelosi i don't think a lot of
people like nancy pelosi i wonder if
that's why her husband drinks uh i don't
know i don't know
um
but wasn't there a clip and this stupid
daily show thing i watched uh where you
were like
it's treason and treason you get uh uh
killed or something like that implying
and what everyone said was you were
implying nancy pelosi should be killed
because nancy pelosi committed treason
and the punishment for treason is death
right could that be extreme rhetoric
that would be good that would be the
extreme punishment but there's also
prison right that's not the one you said
no i didn't i didn't call for her to be
killed no i know you didn't call but
even by
by using like there's so many things i
do think it's i do think people who are
elected and hold and we swear an oath
and we we're to defend the constitution
we are supposed to uphold the law 100
and nancy pelosi and and and i'll say
joe biden and and many others that will
not secure our border right i believe
that is committing treason because they
are they are allowing an invasion into
our country and it's breaking our laws
and they are they're encouraging it
they're turning their back on it and
they're just washing their hands of it
at the same time nancy pelosi and all
the democrats that want sanctuary cities
where they're harboring people that
broke laws to come into our country
when do we acknowledge that these
elected leaders that swore an oath to
uphold our constitution our lives what
do we call this at what what do we call
it
actually i call it treason
that's a good point i think legally
treason is providing aid uh aid and
comfort to enemies
so but enemies have to be declared by
congress i'm pretty sure if it was like
an isis sanctuary city in delaware
there is a very serious problem that um
i would say the cartels are our enemies
i i agree we don't call them our enemies
and they are enabling and making this
happen it's human trafficking yeah on a
scale you've never seen before
and they also work inside our country
they the cartels since biden the biden
has taken over
they have they have moved into our
country this is what we've been told
when i went on my border trip and they
are actually they are there's a massive
network in our country did you know
obama gave him guns
yeah the fast and the furious program
you know there is that's right they gave
yeah they gave guns to cartels so uh
good point i think you're if you're
probably i'm not calling for the death
penalty of anyone yeah but but i think
the american people deserve better but
i want to i just want to address uh i
want to edit this uh
people people don't understand what we
hear a lot from like tucker carlson and
people on the right is that the
democrats are bringing in illegal
immigrants so they can vote for them and
then the left says they can't vote
that's wrong
and both sides are wrong
when california brings in a million
illegal immigrants and refuses to abide
by federal law
they get an extra electoral college vote
this gives california an extra
congressional seat which gives them more
power to vote in congress
that is subversion so perhaps a
seditious conspiracy i suppose to steal
power from the other states in the union
to be fair i don't even think illegal
immigrants want to move to california
right now they they get free health care
under 26. so uh or there's some kind of
program like that so this is the issue
right this is why trump wanted the
citizenship question
because sanctuary states like california
know they get extra seats so they've
recently lost new york lost one because
people are fleeing but i believe that's
the real game plan you bring them in
right before a census as many as you can
you do the census you're gonna get extra
votes for the presidential election so
illegal immigrants don't vote personally
but that extra congressional seat that's
a solid vote and we're talking about 538
so that is a huge huge advantage one or
two extra votes at what point
are you going to see a state like texas
say
what they are doing by not abiding by
federal law is subverting now what did
we see in the first civil war it was the
fugitive slave act the south said we
have a federal law if a slave escapes to
the north the north has to return them
and the north said no we won't now
interestingly i mean i agree the north
shore right they should not have been
doing that they should have been saying
no some things are just morally
abhorrent think about where that brings
us today
what happens when they when the
republicans pass a federal law saying if
a woman
takes a viable pr is pregnant with a
viable baby and flees to a state for an
abortion the state must return to the
state of residence and they say no
all of a sudden now you're going to be
entering the same territory when texas
says california is violating federal law
for political power we say no
at what point to your point is someone
going to say we demand the politician
subverting this country be held
accountable and what form does that take
i think impeachment i think nancy pelosi
should not be allowed to run i think she
forfeits office and then we can bring in
whoever else who might run the district
and you know what maybe even might be
more progressive than she is don't no
don't care vote forever you want san
francisco but get the corruption out of
there
no it's correct we have to hold people
accountable because
we're we are falling apart
we're falling apart and it that's every
single that affects everybody yeah even
like there's a bunch of people that
don't even vote could care less
and and they're losing them for sure
yeah he did
he did yep a lot of first-time voters he
absolutely but i'm you know i'm i'm one
i'll attack the republicans
sometimes more than i attack the
democrats because i feel like
republicans have have let me down so
many times
i didn't even vote for mitt romney i
couldn't even vote i was like i can't
vote for this guy
i mean yeah i know one yeah and i didn't
want barack obama my goodness but i
didn't definitely did not want mitt
romney that romney thing is one more
point for our friendship buddy um
it's kind of crazy because i voted for
trump in 2020 but not 2016. yeah but
after seeing what he did
if i could go back in time i'd vote for
him in 2016. oh
yeah i was unapologetically all in like
ridiculously all in for president trump
and i still am i love the guy absolutely
love him is he perfect no but you want
to know something as messy as our world
is and as screwed up as our country is i
want to put the meanest toughest most
successful proven leader in there to fix
it for us all and i think that's what we
need i don't understand why he's not the
preferred candidate of antifa if they
really think that he has this
destabilizing force who's going to go in
and just gut the country they should be
voting for him being like oh no oh no
it's trump
right
they just believe it's like he the the
democrats are like he's dismantling our
government once at a time he's firing
people then antifa should be like yeah
actually they should but the fight the
system antifa were also the same ones to
put mask on and and get out there and
riot for the vaccines yeah it was crazy
watching the video of them attacking
people outside of uh
like antifa attacked an anti-censorship
rally and i'm like what
are you pro-corporate these these are
people purchasing corporations then you
had people protest processing outside of
a facility against mandated vaccines uh
vaccine mandates and antifa attacks them
too and i'm like they're opposing
government authority yeah then i love
the memes where they're like
you know aoc saying the supreme court
shouldn't have the jurisdiction over uh
abortion and it's like okay they
literally ruled that like you agree with
them they said they were sending
authority and giving back to the states
and then but aoc wants jurisdiction
transferred to a different federal court
anyway yeah she just wants to completely
take apart the supreme court packing the
court it's fascist attack the court i i
love i love the the ban the guns
democrats leftists like real ones they
like guns there's like the social
socialist rifle association for instance
i think killer ones that hate me love
guns they they love guns so much they
called they called my husband and left a
voicemail on his cell phone this past
weekend and said a lot of nasty things
about me and said this is what i'm going
to do to your wife and then they [ __ ]
their gun and fired it several times i
told you i was sorry about that voice my
mom
yeah that's horrible man i'm sorry that
happened like whenever i
whenever i see people on the right
be attacked with some of the tactics
that i used to criticize on the other
side like i always want to just be like
man that doesn't represent me at all
like that's awful it's awful but how how
often have you heard the left say
respect the diversity of tactics right
that that's a code word for when you see
people getting violent don't try and
stop them or criticize them what
they call it respecting the diversity of
tactics
it's a it's a a what does that even mean
well i remember what happened we used to
like get in trouble
anyone who talked about you know when
protests got violent even around occupy
if someone brought up martin luther king
jr
that'd be like oh that's like a a a a
sell-out it was a sell-out tactic if you
brought up martin luther king jr and
you'd say you know oh he believed in
peaceful protest blah blah blah blah um
they would all they would almost say
that now it is ridiculous when even this
year you see like the fbi posting like
martin luther king day uh uh tweets and
stuff you're like okay that's a little
ridiculous but i i i think that having
him as a role model is certainly not a
bad thing and shouldn't be labeled as a
bad thing
so the diversity of tactics thing just
to clarify the idea is that when we
protest a bunch of people will try
different things
and so if so whenever someone would show
up wearing all black and throw bricks
the organizers would say well we respect
a diversity of tactics what yeah it's
not violence it's breaking the law yeah
it's wrong there should be no respect
for that it's regardless of just like
you said you get more mad at republicans
sometimes yeah i feel like the left
should get really mad at that because
that derails
you know if you're throwing bricks
through windows now the story becomes
bricks through windows not
was this man murdered by the police and
it's like we don't want to take away
from that we if you actually care about
the problem if you want to fix
institutional racism if you want to hold
bad cops accountable and help good cops
you shouldn't be throwing bricks through
windows you should be actually making
your point be out in the streets yeah
peacefully protest um wear your heat
resistant gloves always wear the gloves
guys pretend to be handcuffed and wear
the gloves the left is never going to
hold their own accountable because it's
awful i mean i'm doing it right now but
well i don't know that about january 6th
i was mad yeah i was upset
i was scared i was angry i could not
believe it i was like what is happening
how is this happening yeah this is this
is the way i couldn't believe it the
weird contradiction though they don't
hold each other accountable but they do
falsely accuse each other
like they it's a circular firing squad
is what obama called it yeah so it's
like
you'll watch someone on the left or
something egregious and they'll look at
you and be like so what wasn't there a
famous comedian that just got oh yeah
dave chappelle yes dave chappelle the uh
antifa
threatened the venue i guess and then he
he bailed out the left used to love dave
chappelle
but why who did he attack what what was
that it was because of his transphobic
remarks
so what were his transphobic remarks
because i get accused of that too
uh i mean he's made a lot of jokes about
like the whole trans issue i think he's
kind of pigeonholed himself in that way
uh i don't think they're super funny
personally but like
i mean
obviously the left has decided that the
trans issue is like taking priority
right now it's the gold medal because
it's like the ultimate lie that you have
to believe in order to be part of their
group
um
so like some of the venue staff was
doing a strike and
uh
then the venue i think was just sorry
that they got caught they kind of wanted
to have him on under their radar and
then apologize afterwards
i saw their post on instagram about it
saying like we want to be a safe space
for everyone we're not we're not just a
black box with people in it we're like a
home for but we're not out of expression
except for
dave chappelle and also you know that
like the next venue that is willing to
overlook that is eager to have him
because he sells out everywhere wow what
what the left
doesn't realize
you know i've been doing stand-up for
20 years i've seen chappelle perform in
front of 20 people in front of you know
sold out crowds um
what they don't understand is they're
actually pushing more people
to the right because there are so many
comedy fans
of who are fans of offensive comedy
i say offensive things i'm a fan of
offensive comedy because a lot of good
comedy it comes from trauma you know
when people when people would ask me in
interviews like were you the class clown
i'm like nope the class clown beat me up
uh like a lot of comics are sad right i
remember getting into comedy because i
had a really rough childhood and you'd
use humor to kind of
uh escape and same with you know um even
politics if you can make someone who
disagrees with you laugh that breaks the
ice and now you can have a conversation
right
and
so what's happening is comics also they
don't take crap
and they double down because to them
comedy is the religion which means that
i am constantly trying to walk that line
and see how far it can take an audience
where they get scared scared scared
scared and then i'm gonna hit him with a
punch line and then they're gonna laugh
even harder because they thought they
were gonna disagree so chappelle had
like yeah i'm not a huge fan either mary
of like some of the early like trans
jokes i'm like oh that was kind of easy
whatever didn't think they were like
hateful by any means
then he gets attacked as like the
world's worst you know transphobe
whatever which is also not true
physically assaulted on stage yeah by
the way yeah
does the same thing that this uh
representative was yeah
um and so what happened in i don't think
his last special either his last special
or second to last special is he tells
this really touching story about a trans
friend of his who was a comic who he
would bring out on the road with him and
or or have open a couple times and
it was really beautiful and you could
tell that was him as an artist trying to
grapple with what was happening and then
they just went after him harder and and
his friend by the way committed suicide
um and he tells that in the story so
it's this tragic story and
it's what good art should be it's what
good comedy should be it's honest it's
edgy it's dealing with um the adversity
that he's facing and then again they are
acting like this dude wants trans people
locked up they are acting like he has
political power and he isn't just an
artist so now he's just labeled as that
and it's driving all these comedy fans
away from the left because they go oh
you just don't care about freedom of
speech or comedy it's the it's the
recurring theme of the meme where the
guy's standing in the middle and then
someone on the left shoves him to the
right and then he gets picked up and
they're like are you all right and the
left goes why are you siding with them
right
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you